I know it looks like I'm standing up
here by myself but I am not I am
hundreds of people I'm hundreds of
people I'm the day where are the Daniels
Daniels Jonathan leyline the entire crew
my bay Michelle key Steph the entire art
group of artists who made this movie we
just won an Oscar to my family
my beautiful husband Christopher Guest
our daughters
Annie and Ruby
my sister Kelly we just won an Oscar
to all of the people who have supported
the genre movies that I have made for
all these years the thousands and
hundreds of thousands of people we just
won an Oscar together
and my mother and my father were both
nominated for Oscars in different
categories
I just want an Oscar
my mom is 84 years old and she's at home
watching Mom
oh he just won an Oscar
my journey started on a boat I spent a
year in a refugee camp
and somehow
I ended up here on Hollywood's biggest
stage
they say stories like this only happen
in the movies I cannot believe it's
happening to me this this is the
American dream
dreams are something you have to believe
in I almost gave up on mine to all of
you out there please keep your dreams
alive
thank you thank you
for all the little boys and girls who
look like me watching tonight
this is a Beacon of Hope and
possibilities
this is proof
the dreams dream big and dreams do come
true
and ladies don't let anybody tell you
you are ever past your Prime you never
give up
foreign
[Music]